with Bernie Sanders firmly in control of
the Democratic race Michael Bloomberg
vows to fight on Trump's intelligence
community reportedly warns him that
Russia wants him re-elected and
president from previews movies i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by Express VPN
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at Express at VPN calm
slash pens so everybody is now beginning
to realize that Bernie Sanders gonna be
the nominee
and the media are freaking out about it
which is why maybe they should have
spent like five seconds asking him I
don't know sometime over the past 80
years about his viewpoints
he's something that's a long time the
man's been in politics since Richard
Nixon was president and no one has ever
asked him like a simple question hey
you're all for nationalization of
Industry you love Cuba you're like
Venezuela Nicaragua you like them you
honeymoon did in the USSR what's your
deal man like nope nope no questions
asked no questions asked he was just
kind of kooky friendly guy why would we
ask him a question
he's like my kooky socialist uncle why
would and so now you're gonna get him as
the nominee guys you you bought this
ticket and you're taking this ride the
media are freaking out over it because
they're beginning to realize that Bernie
Sanders is uniquely vulnerable candidate
now the question for Bernie Sanders in
the upcoming Trump versus Sanders death
match cage match the big question for
Bernie Sanders is going to be whether
Bernie Sanders performs like Generic
Democrat or whether they give performs
not like canary democrat so in the last
election cycle is an open question
really is not answerable until we
actually get to the election in the last
election cycle one of the great lies
about the last election cycle is that
Donald Trump wildly outperformed other
Republican presidential candidates this
is simply not true he performed
basically the same as Mitt Romney he
actually won fewer absolute votes in
Wisconsin than Mitt Romney did it's just
no one showed up to vote for Hillary
Clinton the going theory is that Donald
Trump because he was so out of the box
because he said so many crazy things
because of the grabbing the p-word tape
because of all of that that he would
significantly underperform other
Republican candidates for president
instead he performed pretty much
directly in line with Bush circa 2000
circa 2000 for Mitt Romney circa 2012
the only candidate who wildly
underperformed was John McCain and that
was because Barack Obama wildly
overperformed but in terms of both
absolute vote counts and in terms of
percentage in particular States he
performed within like a point or two of
Mitt Romney in virtually every state did
Donald Trump and people were asking why
and the answer is because so much of the
Trump vote and so much of the Romney
vote was an anti left vote and so
was this very solid core of Republicans
who were going to end independence who
are going to vote against the Democrats
no matter what and Donald Trump didn't
change that in fact 2016 ended up not
being a referendum on Donald Trump and
his personality quirks and fables and
all of his personality flaws instead it
ended up being a referendum on Hillary
Clinton a bunch of independents didn't
show up to vote for her a bunch of
Democrats didn't show up to vote for her
so Trump who appeared to be really out
of the box ends up performing exactly
like generic Republican and Hillary
Clinton ends up underperforming generic
Democrat or at least underperforming
Barack Obama right because the reality
is that that election looks a lot like
the election of 2004 it looks a lot like
in terms of just the straight numbers
looks a lot like the election of 2004 it
doesn't look like oh wait looks a little
more like 12 and it looks a lot like
2004 2016 okay now fast forward to 2020
so Bernie Sanders is a crazy person and
Bernie Sanders is a socialist who
threatens the free market structures of
the United States who has suggested
direct intervention by the federal
government into every area of American
life he has suggested national rent
control which would destroy the real
estate market he has suggested a green
new deal that would essentially
nationalize huge swathes of the energy
sector he has suggested procedures that
would ultimately involve nationalizing
banks right he actually wants to
communal eyes or nanotech municipal eyes
or nationalized banks he wants the post
office to become a lender of first
resort
Bernie Sanders wants the federal
government to be first and foremost in
your life he was probably the majority
of the of the American economy run owned
or or at least heavily heavily
supervised by the American government
that is gonna have a real impact also on
foreign policy Bernie Sanders is
anti-american what I mean is that he
actually believes that America is a
nefarious force in the world that
minimizing America's capacity to project
force around the world would not only be
in the interest of Americans but
presumably in the interest of his
socialist brethren around the world and
that we would be less offensive if we
were treated inside earned borders and
if we gave the lead to countries like
Russia and China and allowed them to do
basically whatever they want I mean he
literally tweeted out the other day that
America's military budget is too large
what if we used all of that to
redistribute peace around the world
basically what if we used all of that
money for social safety programs he's
campaigning on the basis of the song
imagine so is he going to perform like
Generic Democrat
like Hillary Clinton or is he gonna
underperform Hillary Clinton now I would
bet that he's gonna underperform Hillary
Clinton the reason is that Hillary
Clinton performed very solidly with
suburban women right it's a real hole
for Trump one of the big questions in
2018 was how Trump was going to perform
among suburban women and he really
underperformed in 2018 among suburban
women in 2016
basically Trump traded rural white men
for suburban women that was the
straight-up trade Mitt Romney did pretty
well with suburban white women
particularly married white women living
in the suburbs he did real well and he
didn't do quite as well rural voters
Trump did great among rural voters and
he lost a lot of the suburbs and in 2018
that came back to bite him because a lot
of the rural folks showed up but every
suburban voters showed up every urban
voters showed up and the Democrats
swamped the Republicans and
congressional elections across the
country well what about Bernie
yeah Hillary Clinton is not threatening
to suburban women Bernie Sanders is
almost tailor-made to make suburban
women rethink their vote for Democrats
number one his Bernie bros are just as
toxic in terms of their masculinity has
anything Trump has ever done number two
he's a he's a real threat remember
George W Bush in 2004 won the so-called
security mom's people who are concerned
about their security and the security of
their children right the bush one those
people they were supposed to go for
Kerry Bush one them and at the same time
suburban women many of them have kids
families that's why they're living in
the suburbs in the first place a solid
economy is something that they would
like Bernie threatens that bernie is
somebody they find very threatening
so suburban women could rethink that and
maybe cast their vote for Trump I said
it in an earlier podcast that they would
hold their nose and vote for Trump and
of course not talking about the women
who voted for Trump in 2016 they don't
have to hold their notes I'm talking
specifically about the female voters who
didn't vote Republican in 2018 who voted
Democrat or who voted Democrat in 2016 a
lot of those women are gonna have to
look at Bernie and say okay he's a
threat to my family his agenda is a
threat to my 401 K and forget about
whatever Trump is right Trump she add
rings home for these women and for many
people right he may not be a nice guy he
may sit dumb crap on Twitter but is he a
threat to the very status of the
American economy clearly not the
American economy's been doing
gangbusters
under Trump is he a threat to America on
the world stage as he had threats for
American military obviously not
so the question of Bernie Sanders wildly
over-performing Hillary Clinton I don't
think that there's any shot of that does
he wildly underperform Hillary Clinton
well I think he doesn't worse among
women and particularly among suburban
women I think that he does he does
probably better among young voters but
they don't show up to vote as much and
he does way worse among voters over the
age of 65 he's not comforting voters
over the age of 65 who show up in droves
that those voters remember when
communism was the bad guy like Bernie
Sanders is the guy who watches Air Force
One and roots for the Russian
revolutionaries Bernie Sanders is the
guy who watched Red Dawn and he wondered
why pose juvenile delinquents are up in
the woods shooting all good guys so why
exactly would anybody over the age of 50
who remembers the Soviet Union why would
they vote for Bernie Sanders so the the
going theory among all of these sort of
political wrongs is that Bernie will
wildly underperformed now it's possible
that's wrong it's possible that Bernie
performs exactly like Hillary that we
are so polarized as a country you can
put anybody you can put a bag of flaming
dog crap at the top of the Democratic
ticket and they will perform exactly
like Hillary Clinton that there is no
such thing as underperforming Hillary
possible possible but the Democrats are
taking an awful risk Vader they'd better
hope that it works and members of the
media are beginning to realize that I'll
show you that in just one second first
let's talk about how you can save time
and how you can save money so if you run
a small business if you send a lot of
mail if you're somebody who has to use
the post office a lot you know it's kind
of a pain in the butt to take all those
packages put them in back here car
schlep them over to the post office even
if you have people who do that for you
you have to pay them in order to do that
they have to go to the post office they
have to wait in line well I do owe them
that when you could just do all of this
directly from your office or directly
from home saves your time and it saves
you money stamps comm it's completely
online which saves you time
no more inconvenient trips to the post
office in postage rates keep going up
with stamps calm you save five cents off
every first-class stamp and up to 40%
off shipping rates that kind of savings
really does add up especially for small
businesses simply use your computer to
print official US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready you just handed to the
mail carrier you can drop it off in the
mailbox it is indeed that simply get the
discounted postage rates you can't get
it the post office also it's not as a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters and there's no equipment
to lease and no long-term commitment
there's a reason
700,000 small business is already
stamps.com including we here at the
daily where you stamps com2 right now my
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage ends digital scale no long term
commitment just go to stamps com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that is stamps
com enter promo code at Shapiro
stamps.com enter Shapiro okay so let's
say that Bernie Sanders were to wildly
underperform Donald Trump so what
exactly would that look like in terms of
which states are back in play the answer
is a lot of states are in play now
people tend to think that Trump squeaked
it out he did squeak it out but he
squeaked it out because there are a lot
of states that were very close they won
for Hillary Clinton if you look at the
battleground states there were many many
states many battleground states that
were extrude that were absolute
squeakers so Trump squeaked it out in
Michigan he squeaked it out in
Pennsylvania he squeaked it out in
Wisconsin now there's some new there's
some new polling that shows that that
Donald Trump is leading pretty heavily
in Wisconsin against whoever runs
against him so if he wins Wisconsin the
elections over if he holds all the other
states any wins Wisconsin
he's reelected now the chances that
Bernie's gonna win Florida and they are
very bad I think the Bernie is gonna run
horribly in Florida first of all you
have the Cuban expatriate population
Bernie Sanders basically wishes that he
had been a member of the Cuban
Revolution I mean he literally had he's
on tape talking about how he feels bad
that the United States opposed the
Castro's so he ain't gonna go great in
Miami man there's a big Jewish
population an older Jewish population
that looks at Bernie Sanders and
contrary to public opinion and popular
opinion they don't look at Bernie
Sanders and say oh look a fellow old Jew
instead they look at Bernie Sanders and
see a guy who campaigns with Linda
Sarsour I got her campaigns with a low
hon Omar and Rasheed it to liebe and
he's a threat to the State of Israel
they're not gonna love Bernie Sanders
either so Bernie basically is giving up
Florida okay which means that the other
battleground states that Trump won in
those states that were apparently
supremely close in favor of Donald Trump
none of those I see moving back into the
Democratic aisle right I don't see Ohio
moving back Democratic impact has gotten
redder since President Trump won that
state you could theoretically see
Arizona realigning but I don't see how
Arizona really realigns understand ders
considering how extreme he is on
immigration
remember even Kyrsten Sinema who is the
very
hen at heart left senator from Arizona
she has campaign to the right she's
actually voted to the right she's vote
she's famously during the State of the
Union stood up and cheered that from tax
cuts because Arizona is fairly Trumpy
some of the other states that Democrats
were hoping to flip like Georgia that is
not flipping for burning Georgia is not
flipping blue for Bernie it's not a
thing that's going to happen Indiana not
flipping blue for burning Iowa has
gotten redder not bluer so they're not a
lot of Republican states that are up for
grabs
other than Pennsylvania Michigan
Wisconsin in the last election cycle and
right now obviously if you look at
Wisconsin Trump's running away with
Wisconsin so heavy odds on Trump to be
reelected if Bernie Sanders is the
nominee beyond that you have New
Hampshire which Bernie tends to a
performing because neighboring to his
state of Vermont but New Hampshire
Hillary only one that by 0.3 seven
percent of the vote Bernie could alien
there are a lot of new hampshirites who
are not big into heavy taxation that's
why they're living in New Hampshire and
not Massachusetts and so that state
could easily flip for Trump Minnesota
could easily flip for Trump Nevada could
certainly flip for Trump I mean I don't
like Bernie has wild popularity in
Nevada particularly since he's
threatening to take away all of the
health care plans for union members even
while he lies about it you could see
Colorado fairly easily
shift in favor of President Trump
because Colorado is a purple state it is
not an overtly blue state Virginia could
shift for Trump especially as a backlash
to the Democratic assembly in Virginia
where she's been pushing further and
further left New Mexico which was not
particularly close could shift for Trump
so you could theoretically see a
situation in which the vast majority of
states go for president Trump you could
see Trump pick up an additional one two
three four five six maybe up to seven
additional states president from and
that would be just a whopping blow out
can you imagine a world in which Donald
Trump walks away from this election
cycle winning 37 to 40 states can you
imagine that because that's a real
possibility the media can imagine this
here's a quick mashup that I can't
remember who cut this maybe the
Washington Examiner there's a quick
mashup of members of the media
absolutely in a state of sheer panic
over the fact that Bernie Sanders
to be the nominee the truth is Bernie
Sanders is on a trajectory to be the
Democratic nominee to me he just don't
see him having any shot in a general
election I'm panicked I am absolutely
mad no one but Bernie Stephanie come on
he's an anarchist he would love to burn
down the United States if we nominate a
socialist like Bernie Sanders we're
gonna lose it'll be like George McGovern
it'll be a blowout Tom Perez needs to
step down he's a joke he's a clown he
can't run the Democratic Party anymore
it's lost its way just just amazing so
they're beginning to realize this is a
mistake meanwhile the Democratic
operational owner they're desperately
praying that somebody will provide a
rival to Bernie which is why Bloomberg
is still on that stage in just one
second we're gonna get to the
possibility of an open convention right
now over at 538 if you look at their
estimates of what they think is going to
happen right now they say that the
number one possibility at 2 and 5
possibility no majority for any
candidate going into the Democratic
convention which means an open
convention what does that mean I'll
explain in just one second first let's
talk about the importance of good sleep
so my wife right now is like right on
the verge of going into labor like it
could happen in the middle of the show
my phone is on okay and that means we
are not sleeping great but when we are
able to sleep it is only because of the
comfort and luxury of a-helix sleep
mattress because you see helix is made
just for us helix is specifically made
just for us we live in an era of
personalization we can get nearly any
product personalized for you and yet
people are just going down to big box
mattress stores and picking up whatever
happens to be there you lie on it for
like one second some bring some bowling
ball and they bounce it on the mesh like
oh that looks like the good mattress you
have no idea instead what you should be
using is helix sleep
helix sleep has a quiz that just takes
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper a hot sleeper whether you
like a pleasure from med with helix
there's no more confusion and no more
compromising helix sleep is rated the
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine and CNN which is like I don't
know how they can sleep at night at all
but they call it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on just go
to helix sleep comm slash man take their
two-minute sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty yet to try
it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
hilux is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders for our listeners
get up to $200 off at helix sleep comm
/ban helix sleep comm slash man go check
them out right now supremely comfortable
mattresses go check them out right now
okay so as I say 538 right now suggest
that the most likely scenario in the
Democratic primaries is that nobody
emerges with a majority of the delegates
now I think that's wrong I think that
Sanders probably ends up winning a
majority of Delegates
but the Democratic Party is desperately
desperately hoping that that's what
happens right right now right now 538 is
estimating that Bloomberg could win up
to $1,000 gets that Biden could still
win up to a thousand delegates which is
why I think that their estimates are way
off unless Biden shows very strong in
Nevada
tomorrow right the Nevada caucuses are
tomorrow but this is why you're starting
to see this move inside the Democratic
Party trying to hold off Sanders even if
he has a plurality of the delegates so
you'll remember back at that bleep show
debate the other night every Democrat on
stage was asked should the delegate
leader in the clubhouse be the person
who gets the nomination even if they
don't want a majority and every single
person on the stage said no every single
person on the stage said we have to let
the process play out what they mean by
that is open convention I get to barter
my delegates for a position in your
cabinet three of us gets decide together
and make you the president or the
presidential nominee Harry Reid who's
the former Senate Majority Leader he
says the Bernie Sanders should need more
than a plurality to win the Democratic
nomination he came out yesterday and
dismissed suggestions from Sanders and
his supporters that he should become the
nominee if he finishes with a plurality
lead ahead of the candidates but short
of the 1991 delegates needed to secure
the nomination outright according to the
Washington Post Reid says here's how I
feel about this I don't think anybody
Bernie Sanders or anyone else should
simply get the nomination because they
have 30% of the delegates and no one
else has that many let's say he has
thirty five percent well 65 percent he
doesn't have or that person doesn't have
I think we have to let the system work
its way out right now that is the
electoral scenario that is a scenario
that is geared for disaster for the
Democrats if the Democrats deny Bernie
the nomination on the basis that he
doesn't have a majority of Delegates B
has a plurality of Delegates they risk
the ire of the Bernie Bros simply
walking out because remember Bernie
started as a not a member of the
Democratic Party and he probably has no
problem with leaving the Democratic
Party over this again but this is
the reason why Michael Bloomberg is
pouring money into this race he feels
like if he denies a shot to Bernie but
if he denies it and maybe just maybe his
pledges of cash I mean it's always
worked from before right Bloomberg has
always been able to basically bribe
everybody around him in New York City to
shut the hell up
so Bloomberg's plan is I don't win as
many delegates as Bernie he doesn't win
a majority of Delegates I don't have as
many delegates but I do have this giant
bag of cash right here I'm the person
who is most likely to beat Donald Trump
probably I'm not giving up a lot of the
states like Bloomberg would be
competitive in Florida in a way that
Bernie Sanders would not for example so
you can see Bloomberg going to the upper
echelon of the Democratic Party and
saying okay you might lose the Bernie
bros but the vast majority of them are
getting about Democrat anyway Bernie's
coalition is not all that strong and
here is a giant gob of money here is
just here's a here's three billion
dollars right Bernie that bloomberg is
worth sixty five billion dollars sixty
five billion dollars okay let's put it
this way in the last election cycle the
Trump campaign spent about a billion
dollars Bloomberg could drop five
billion dollars into this race
personally personally and not even dent
his personal fortune in this areas why
so he could go to the Democratic Party
and hey listen you know you may think
that you're gonna piss off the Bernie
bros and the Bernie supporters what if I
just give you five billion dollars what
if I just what if I just sink several
million dollars into every single
Democratic Party race around the country
can you have to worry about fundraising
any more if I worry about anything I
will literally just buy the party I will
go to the party in Oklahoma and I will
say to the party in Oklahoma which has
never been competitive here is a hundred
million dollars enjoy yourselves
that's what Bloomberg is hoping for
which is why Bloomberg is staying in
this campaign and Bloomberg is sounding
the alarm right the campaign manager
Bloomberg's campaign manager came out
yesterday said there may not be much
campaign after Super Tuesday right so
Biden better get the hell out because if
Biden is still in and he splits the vote
with Bloomberg and Bernie just runs
right down that left flank and if he
takes the inside rail and wins all those
primaries it's over what they are saying
basically is just an irony the
nomination Justin I'm the nomination and
Michael Bloomberg will sweep in with
this giant bag of cash and then he will
make things right with the world
here was Bloomberg's campaign manager
suggesting that basically Biden used to
get the hell out right now
think Mike is clearly firmly in second
place in March states our polling shows
that public polling shows that it also
shows Bernie Sanders growing that lead
over Mike and everyone else in the field
and there's a real possibility because
California is so big and so early in the
schedule this year that burning racks up
a lead in that state on Super Tuesday
that quite frankly is just uncatchable
and so I think this you know listen I
think we may know a lot about this
campaign very early it may be that
there's not much of a campaign in March
after that day but we're certainly
fighting as hard as we can to make sure
that there is I mean that that is them
putting up the smoke signal to the
Democratic Party guys see this bag of
cash you see how it's gradually receding
into the distance you see that he's that
happening right now well maybe you
better some of these other people to get
out of the way meanwhile Elizabeth
Warren just punching that horse
from Blazing Saddles as I said yesterday
that Elizabeth Warren in the middle of
that debate just decided that she was
gonna punch a horse no one knew why
right she's in the Bernie Sanders Lane
and she's like what if I just punch
Bloomberg just over and over for no
reason and from Blazing Saddles
punching the horse oh she continues to
punch the horse she's out there today
saying that she used to teach contract
law and she's offering to release women
from their NDA's by texting an NDA
released to Michael Bloomberg to release
them from their NDA's because she
punched Bloomberg over all of this and
she's so terrible elizabeth warren and
she's desperately trying to get back
into this race she's also wildly
dishonest but if her strategy is to turn
on Bloomberg she's gonna make Sanders
the nominee right I mean that is
obviously what is going this is a
two-person race and it's gonna be even
more of a two-person race after Biden
gets destroyed tomorrow Biden is toast
combined was not even alive on that
debate stage nobody paid one whit of
attention to Joe Biden your national
poll leader for nearly Wired wire that
guy Joe Biden he was on the stage and
every treat everybody treated him like
he was a piece of the scenery they
treated him like his podium was there
and he was not behind it
I think he's gonna chill act amaro in
Nevada I think he's gonna chill Acton in
South Carolina I think the Biden is done
and that means this is a two-man race
Sanders and Bloomberg which really means
that Sanders has the upper the upper
hand right here and then that's why
Bloomberg points out and he's correct
that the real winner of the debate the
other night was Donald Trump the real
winner in the debate last night was
Donald Trump
because I worry that we may very well be
on the way to nominating somebody who
cannot win in November
and if we choose a candidate who appeals
to a small base like senator Sanders it
will be a fatal error okay so that's his
campaign that's his campaign we're gonna
get two more of this and we're gonna get
to President Trump himself and his own
foibles and as I've said if Bernie
Sanders is the nominee Trump does not
have room to make a mistake because if
Trump loses to Bernie Sanders that is on
no one no one but president Trump
everything else is baked into the cake
okay we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about a sad
reality of life that is two out of three
dudes are going to experience some form
of male pattern baldness by the time
they are 35 yep I like my hair I'm not
in the mood to lose it and this is why I
recommend keeps with today's
advancements in science keeps offers
proven treatments that can combat the
symptoms of hair loss and keep and help
you keep the hair that you have at half
the cost of your local pharmacy
prevention is key because once the hair
starts to go very difficult to regrow
that hair keeps is up to 90% effective
at reducing and stopping further hair
loss the sooner you start using keeps
the more hair you save so now would be
the time to get this done
thanks to keeps you no longer have to go
to a doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription now you can visit a doctor
online and get your hair loss medication
delivered discreetly to your home like
my hair is very important to me I love
my dad but my dad has lost a lot of his
hair obviously everybody my mom's family
lost their hair and that is not rare
male pattern baldness is just a thing
that naturally happens to people as they
get older but there's no reason why you
should have to suffer through that
increasing bald spot instead go check
out keeps right now if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
keep us calm slash men receive your
first month of treatment for free that
is ke e PS calm /ban keeps calm at /ban
and receive your first month of
treatment for free ok so with all of
this said with Michael Bloomberg valine
to fight on and when Michael Bloomberg
having botched that debate and when
Michael Bloomberg's momentum apparently
blunted and Elizabeth Warren sitting
there just wailing away at him for no
apparent reason the onus is now on
President Trump to beat Bernie Sanders
okay and beat him like a redheaded
stepchild I mean like that that is the
that is what Trump has to do in this
election and there's good news President
Trump is a weapon okay the man is
fantastic at destroying people himself
too but he's been
has taken destroying other people and he
took Hillary Clinton he broke her into
little pieces and then he flushed her
Donald Trump is a destroyer
he's the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man they
chose the form of their destroyer and
now he has come to New York City and in
Donald Trump is fantastic at this right
you give him a piece of material and
he's like a dog with a bone he's never
going to let it go once I pointed out
the other day after Bloomberg went after
Bernie and his lakeside dasha
after after that happened I said if you
think that was bad when Bloomberg went
after Bernie
wait until Donald Trump makes a little
model of the lakeside dasha
and starts bringing it around to his
campaign rallies wait until he actually
does a campaign in front of that
lakeside dasha in Vermont on Lake
Champlain wait until Donald Trump goes
to that dasha and prize up a piece of
the floorboard and then physically beats
Bernie Sanders on stage with it like
Donald Trump may do any or all of these
things right that that is done that is
Donald from specialty she's got a lot to
work with with Bernie Sanders he's got
ads he can work with in Pennsylvania
right right now he's trailing Bernie in
Pennsylvania according to the latest
polling not a single ad has been put out
in Pennsylvania
about the fact that Bernie Sanders wants
to ban fracking which is responsible for
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
jobs in the state of Pennsylvania I mean
nothing has been done in the state of
Pennsylvania about the fact of
Pittsburgh you know the number one
industry in Pittsburgh is the number one
industry in Pittsburgh is the health
care industry
if you nationalize the healthcare
industry you know what happens to a lot
of those jobs they're gone right
everybody in health insurance kaput so
that it's amazing to me how whenever
people talk about job loss and they talk
about trade or you know create an awful
lot of job loss the millions of people
working in health care and health
insurance would be out of work if
nationalization of the industry were to
happen now those jobs don't
automatically get transferred over to
the government gang a lot of people in a
battle work Pittsburgh it moved from a
steel working town into a healthcare
centric town filled with hospitals and
medical centers what do you think
happens when Bernie nationalizes the
health care system when he goes full NHS
which by the way is the second step to
Medicare for all Medicare for all starts
with low reimbursement rates then when
hospitals can no longer perform the
hospital's end up nationalized and the
doctors end up working directly for the
government and that is the way that that
ends up working so what do you think
Trump is going to do with all that in
Pennsylvania the answer is an awful lot
an awful lot what do you think Trump is
gonna do about the the fact that Bernie
Sanders
in the state of Michigan stands against
the the capacity of auto companies to
build autos that the American people
like remember Bernie basically wants to
shut down the fossil fuel industry what
do you think makes the economy of
Michigan go I mean that's an auto based
economy so Trump has plenty to work with
in other words so what this means is
that Trump has to avoid the big boo-boo
this is always the problem
so Trump has two specific obstacles one
is the possibility of an economic
downturn that one is outside of his
control and the other is how Trump acts
and that one is certainly within his
control and I know that we in the
Republican Party have this fondness for
treating Donald Trump is sort of a quasi
child then when he does something wrong
it's like oh isn't that cute and then we
done something right like oh we're so
proud of him
okay but here's the deal President Trump
is Jesus the man is in his 70s he's in
he's inordinately successful he ran for
president once and he became president
he obviously has the capacity to do
smart things so why would we not want
him to do those things all the time
especially when the alternative then
people said it was a flight 93 election
against Hillary Clinton and I argued
it's not really a flight 93 election
like it's bad but it isn't a flight
night it's not like the plane that the
America's plane is going down either way
so charge the cockpit with Bernie it's a
flight 93 election right you have now
radicalized half the population into
almost full-scale come come this is a
flight 93 election so Trump has to go
for broke and not only does he have to
go for broke has to run a strong
campaign because it's on him if you get
a candidate as weak as Bernie as
unpopular as Bernie's policies are the
American people do not want an
octogenarian socialist was pledged to
destroy the American economy and our
foreign policy standing as president of
the United States if you lose to that
that's on you that's on you so they're
only two possibilities for how Trump
loses this election one is the economy
the second is Trump so on the economy
the news today is that the Treasury
yields are absolutely collapsing which
suggests that people are very wary about
the economic future the way that this
works is that the demand for a Treasury
bond and the yield of that Treasury bond
work in inverse proportion so the more
demand there is for a Treasury bond the
more the yield drops so in the yield
drops dramatically that means that
people are investing a lot of money into
bonds and that's what's been happening
in the 10-year Treasury note yield the
10-year of is according to
marketwatch.com the 10-year Treasury
note yield was down three basis points
to one point four nine five the lowest
since
last September the two-year note rate
edged 1.4 basis points lower to 1.3 a 1%
the 30-year bond yield slipped four
point two percent basis points to 1.9 3o
percentage points following well below
its previous all-time low of 1.9 5%
according to market watch calm global
equity benchmarks and US stock futures
fell Friday as the growing number of
cases of the coronavirus outside China
especially in South Korea raised fears
that the damage to supply chains could
hit several major Asian economies which
are linchpins for industries like
semiconductors and automobiles so people
are banking on the fact that coronavirus
may be destroying supply chains this is
certainly true by the way I mean I work
with businesses who work with folks in
Hong Kong and they've been just stifled
like everything is closed over in Hong
Kong everything in China is is closed
it's one of the reasons why you saw I
believe is Wilbur Ross the commerce
secretary suggesting that in the future
people are gonna start investing in
American factories because I mean do you
really want to invest in a country or
every five years there's a SARS or a
mirror's or a or a corona virus outbreak
now we can get some more of the economic
news which is a little scary for the
Trump candidacy and for the global
economy which is even more important
we'll get to that in just one second
but first let's talk about how you make
your business better well here's an easy
way first don't invest in a live animal
market in China but second make sure
that you have all the data about your
own company how can you make sure that
this happens well you don't wanna be
like a pilot flying one without any data
right and without any Brown gear and if
you need all of the data at your
disposal you need everything in your
disposal and this is what NetSuite
brings to the table successful companies
know that in order to grow faster you
must have the right tools whether you're
doing a million 10 million or hundreds
of millions in revenue NetSuite by
Oracle gives you the tools you need to
accelerate your growth with NetSuite you
get a full picture of your business
finance inventory HR customers and more
it's everything you need to grow all in
one place directly from your phone or
computer
NetSuite will give you the visibility
and control you need to make the right
decisions and grow with confidence
that's why NetSuite customers grow
faster than the S&P 500 NetSuite is the
world's number one cloud business system
trusted by more than 19,000 companies is
the last system you'll ever need
NetSuite business grows here schedule
your free product tour right now
receive your free guide to seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash been that is
NetSuite comm slash Bennigan's NetSuite
com
go check them out right now also it is
that glorious time of the week when I
give a shout-out to a daily aware
subscriber is he using you well today
it's Tiffany LaRue on Twitter who knows
the secret to conquering the neverending
work of family life in this picture
Tiffany's magnificent beverage vessel is
resting in her cart across from her her
equally magnificent infant the caption
reads sweet leftist years and my baby
sweet face are getting me through the
long and arduous task of grocery
shopping for my family of 10 whoa
hashtag left his tears tumblr great
stuff family of ten repopulating the
earth with conservatives excellent
excellent work Congrats on the big
family and super adorable baby more
conservative babies make it more babies
of all times make it happen
that's awesome stuff also it's time to
tell you a difficult truth you're not
gonna like it but I can help fix it here
it is if you are consuming daily web
content and you're not a member you're
punishing yourself you're depriving
yourself you masochist you deserve
better you are missing the absolute best
experience in conservative news and
commentary I'm gonna fix that for you
right now out of the kindness of my
heart and the desire for more money in
our coffers if you head to daily
wire.com today and you join any of our
plans you get 10% off when you use promo
code Shapiro well what makes membership
so great you ask glad you asked well
members get our articles had free access
to all of our live broadcast intro
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show select bonus content access
to the mailbag and more also makes
julienne fries plus our new all access
to your gets you an exclusive live
online Q&A discussions with me Andrew
Clavin matt walsh michael moles plus
daily wire writers and special guests
and don't forget you also get the
greatest of all beverage vessels the
leftist here's someone you know i didn't
drink it enough this week that's really
the problem and because i didn't drink
it enough this week i ended up with this
horrible coronavirus disease here that
of that but if you wish to be completely
invulnerable to life's to the syste
toots obviously i can't guarantee it's
gonna happen but you can try it with the
lefty steers tumbler again then it's ten
percent off any plan when you use promo
code shapiro
don't wait join today start the year off
right you're listening to our gist
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so as I say threat number one to
campaign from 2020 is the economy if the
economy collapses anybody could be
President and this is what we learned in
2008 when John McCain had finally
finally peaked in the polls against
Barack Obama the economy collapsed boom
blowout for Obama okay the same thing
could happen here right now market
watchers reporting global equity
benchmarks and US stock futures fell
Friday as the growing number of cases of
the coronavirus outside China especially
in South Korea raised fears that the
damage to supply chains could hit
several major Asian economies which are
linchpins for industries like
semiconductors and automobiles investors
say it's unclear when workers will be
able to return to factory floors some
forecasters suggest car manufacturing
and other industries may not return to
usual production activity until March
the bearish investor sentiment in risk
assets helped boost a demand for haven
bonds which have seen sharp inflows all
week long-term Treasury yields are on
the verge or have already broken through
key levels that investors say could pre
sage further yield the declines worries
about a Chinese and Asian economic
slowdown spilling over into the United
States have also lifted traders
expectations for interest rate cuts
later in the year
despite speeches by senior Fed Reserve
officials suggesting no further easing
was imminent so it's possible that you
get a little more inflation or to jog
things in economic data u.s. existing
home sales for January we're due this
morning economists pullback market watch
expect sales to run an annualized pace
of five point three nine million down
slightly from five point five four
million in December so people are very
worried obviously about coronavirus and
the fallout they're from so that is risk
number one to trump that ones outside
his control then there's the stuff
that's in his control and this is the
stuff like don't look corrupt right look
sounds reasonable right I mean the
president is not corrupt right as far as
I can tell like I'm I'm I know that the
the left has been shouting about
emolument said all of this and then
President Trump abusing the power of his
office in order to accomplish certain
private goals I mean I think the
president is vindictive and thin-skinned
I think the president has a weird notion
that the presidency of the United States
is sort of like a talk radio call like
and that he should use his Twitter
account in order to yell at members of
his administration but every time that
the president is told by his advisors to
back off he generally does it's very
rare the president overrules as his
advisers and then just goes and does
something anyway when he does it ends up
badly right when people inside his
administration are like mr. president
I don't do not deploy rudy guiliani to
ukraine to go root around in 2016
related materials from some I don't care
I like Rudy do that it doesn't work out
great well this happened that he's had
this one Bugaboo and it's been in his
ear this bug in his ear and I get like
an ear worm it's been there since 2016
and that is President Trump believes he
has been unfairly denied credit for his
stunning victory in 2016 because the
media have continued to focus in and the
interference of Russia in the election
he's been saying this for four years at
this point that you guys keep focusing
on Russia Russia this and Russia that
and you keep saying that Russia
interfered at my behest and all of this
stuff and it wasn't it was me okay so a
few things are true one Trump on the
election second Hillary lost the
election third Russia did try to
interfere with the election through
WikiLeaks and distribution of
information for the extent of that
interference online particular on
Facebook has been wildly exaggerated by
the media and by the Senate Democrats
who suggest that Facebook which is
papered with Russian propaganda that
shifted the election there's very little
evidence that is the case as I've talked
about before the actual statistics on
Russian Facebook posts and their reach
is astonishingly minimal I mean
seriously
they are so unsuccessful on Facebook it
makes as one of the companies that is
most successful on Facebook I can tell
you the numbers that were being put out
for Russia's reach we're like ridiculous
like I'm more reach on my personal
Facebook page in one month than the
entire Russian government had in all of
2016 in terms of its in terms of its
sort of interference or at least it's
it's it's sort of attention how many how
many people are paying attention to it
on Facebook but all these things can be
simultaneously true Russia tried to
interfere Russia tried to interfere on
behalf of Trump because they didn't like
Hillary Clinton and they were angry at
Hillary Clinton Russia was aiming for
chaos which they achieved the Democrats
have maximized that to suggest that
Trump in legitimately win and that this
has got under Trump's skin and that's
the last one that is a problem the
reason the last one is a problem is
because when something is under drum
skin he allows himself to make stupid
decisions and this is why he was talking
to Roger stone and this is why he's now
talking about pardoning Roger stone
which makes it look to the general
public as though Roger stone was trying
to funnel him information about
WikiLeaks and then lying in order to
cover for President Trump and then went
to jail and then from pardoned him right
so this is why it's really stupid for
Trump to talk about
rating Roger stone and getting involved
in the Roger stone case President Trump
is the head of the Justice Department
William bar the Attorney General just
recommended a sentence from the Justice
Department now the case itself the the
controversy over the sentencing was very
stupid because the prosecutors
apparently didn't run their sentence
recommendation up the flagpole you're
supposed to do that major cases you go
to the AG AG's office and you say we'd
like to recommend this sentence and then
the AG's office presumably suggests okay
that's it this is good or that sentence
is bad
okay they didn't do that that's why AG
buyer stepped in but at no points at AG
bar suggests that the case was
illegitimate and no point did William
bar say this case is wrong so that means
that the AG's office approved the case
but Trump is ripping on the case right
Trump is like Roger stone should be
exonerate now again there are problems
with the case namely the chief juror in
the case the jury foreman was somebody
who hated around her stone apparently
who hated President Trump that's a good
case for a mistrial it's a good case for
a new trial with a better jury it is not
a case that Roger stone was in fact
innocence of the charges that were being
thrown at him namely lying to Congress
and trying to threaten another witness
Randy credit Co and suggest and and
trying to push Randy critical to suggest
that he was in fact to go between two
wiki leaks whereas Roger stone was
trying to act as a go-between to
WikiLeaks in any case Trump should not
get involved in any of this right Trump
should say let justice take its course I
wasn't involved in this which he wasn't
right by all available evidence Roger
stone would called from be like you know
WikiLeaks he's doing uh you know
WikiLeaks is doing all this stuff inform
me like that's fine okay and then you
hang up and that was like the whole
thing but what the media would like it
to be is Trump's anger Roger stone go
tell WikiLeaks XYZ and and there's no
evidence that ever happened so
you know Trump is always honestly I find
this so bizarre
Trump has pretty much always been
willing to let his subordinates burn it
but apparently with Roger stone he is
not doing that at this point because
Roger stone has shown loyalty to them in
any case here was Trump yesterday
suggesting that he would love to see
Roger stone exonerated this is a dumb
political move because if you don't
believe this turns into a Bernie Sanders
campaign ad an anti corruption Bernie
Sanders campaign ad then you are likely
wrong here is here as president from
talking about Roger stone I want the
process to play out I think that's the
best thing to do
because I'd love to see Roger exonerated
and I'd love to see it happen because I
personally think he was treated very
unfairly they talked about witness
witness tampering but a man that he was
tampering didn't seem to have much of a
problem with them he think they know
each other for years
and it's not like the tampering that I
see on television when you watch a movie
that's called pampering
okay-y again this one falls under why
why you just say I want to see the
process play out and then just stop how
about that how about like after a
sentence you take a break just like a
three second break and think to yourself
do I need to say more do I need to say
more but instead the longoria kicks in
and it's like I'm just going to I'm just
gonna spill that out there okay in other
news today President Trump's reaction to
a new report that Russia attempts to
tamper in this election this is going to
lead the Democrats again to akin to a to
have campaign material depending how
Trump reacts to it so there's a report
today out of the Washington Post and it
suggests that intelligence officials
warned House lawmakers last week that
Russia was interfering in the 2020
campaign to try and get Trump reelected
five people familiar with the matter
said in a disclosure that angered Trump
who complained that Democrats would use
it against him okay so a few things one
again many things can be trolled ones
one of course Russia is going to try to
interfere in 2020 they successfully
through America into chaos in 2016 by
the mere fact of their interference -
are they interfering on behalf of Trump
or are they putting out signals that
they're interfering on behalf of from
specifically in order to give the media
a rationale to attack Trump and to give
Democrats a rationale for leaking that
out there just to get under firm skin
further and to gin up more chaos right
if Russia came out and said we're
interfering on behalf of the Democrats
then firmly be like okay well we better
crack down on this stuff now now now but
instead if they say we're interfering on
behalf of Trump Trump will try to
downplay it because that's what he did
in 2016 and then the Democrats will
suggest that he's in cahoots with the
Russians again which of course is
exactly what they are doing the day
after the February 13th briefing to
lawmakers Trump paraded Joseph McGuire
the outgoing at DNI for allowing it to
take place people familiar with the
exchange said from cited the presence in
the briefing of representative Adam
Schiff Democrat of California who led
the impeachment proceedings against him
as a particular irritant during the
briefing two
House Intelligence Committee Trump's
allies challenged the conclusions
arguing the Trump had been tough on
Russia and strengthen European security
some intelligence officials viewed the
briefing as a tactical error saying that
the official who delivered the
conclusion spoke less pointedly or left
it out they would have avoided angering
the Republicans that intelligence
official shelby pearson as an aid to
mcguire as a reputation of delivering
intelligence in somewhat blunt terms the
president announced wednesday he was
replacing mcguire with richard Grinnell
the ambassador to Germany and an
aggressively vocal Trump supporter but
some current and former officials
speculated the briefing may have played
a role in McGuire's removal to
administration officials said that the
timing was coincidental who now had been
discussions with the administration
about taking on a new role so they okay
so this is being set up right now as
another Trump fires the messenger in
order to replace him with somebody who's
going to suppress Russian interference
in the election right this is the
democratic narrative the democratic
narrative is going to be that President
Trump is firing his outgoing DNI in
order to cover up the fact that Russia
is interfering on his behalf in the 2020
election and replacing him with a hack
like wretch Grinnell right that is that
that is what the narrative is going to
be and watches the media build this out
over the course of the next week what
should President Trump do about that
you should just acknowledge the obvious
of course Russia is attempting to
manipulate our election we are going to
use all of our law enforcement resources
available to prevent Russia from
interfering in the 2020 election we
accept what our intelligence officials
say and we are going to stand and we're
going to stop all of this okay what well
where were Democrats go with that the
answer is they wouldn't have any place
to go with that right if Trump actually
just said that if you just said yes of
course the Russians aren't going to try
to interfere they tried to interfere
last time and their interference last
time didn't mean that Hillary lost she
lost because she lost and if I win this
time it's because I went but we are
going to dedicate all law enforcement
resources to ensuring that America's
elections are untampered with by foreign
actors it wouldn't give the Democrats
any place to go instead because Trump is
so thin-skinned about this the
likelihood is that Trump is going to
simply deny that Russia is interfering I
mean he's done that publicly right here
this is why he was focused on Ukraine
and then right and then that will give
Sanders something to run on it will give
Sanders something to run on because
Sanders will then say from from Toluca
about Russian interference in the
election he likes it he wants it that's
why he's done playing
he fired his own Acting DNI he replaced
them because he didn't like the message
he wants to interpret this is the
narrative they were unspooling even
throughout the Ukrainian investigation
was if we don't impeach him now he's
gonna cheat in the upcoming election now
you can see them building manera okay
over the next two weeks watch this is
going to be the going narrative for the
next two weeks then going narrative is
going to be the intelligence officials
told trump the russians are interfering
and then Trump responded by firing the
messenger in order to cover up Russian
interference you watch this is where
it's going
all of this could be solved with a
little bit of forethought by the Trump
administration all they have to do is
say of course Russia's gonna try to
interfere they root for chaos and you
know who else is rooting for chaos you
guys by maximizing the impact of that
and also we are dedicating law
enforcement to stopping all of this that
that would be and you can see that the
media are itching for the narrative
right the media want the narrative how
do you know the media want the narrative
the way that this is all the the way
that they report these issues so the
Daily Beast's the other day issued a
tweet the tweet suggested that President
Trump had offered Julian Assange a
pardon Julian Assange the WikiLeaks guy
a pardon in return for saying that
Russia didn't interfere in 2016 that
turned out to be not true like at all
there was a legal filing from massages
attorney that contained that allegation
one of the beautiful things about legal
filings is that they are not subject to
defamation okay so if someone says
something in a legal filing they can
allege anything hey I can allege that
John Kerry loved sex with animals in a
legal filing as long as I do it an
illegal filing it's not some family for
the record Jonathan I have no evidence
that John Kerry engages in bestiality
but if I put that in a legal filing then
that is not subject to for defamation
ray or slander it isn't okay so this was
putting a legal filing The Daily Beast
reported as fact they put out there a
tweet reporting as fact that Trump
solicited Julian Assange to say that
WikiLeaks was not a Russian tool and
that Russia had not interfered in 2016
and then he would offer him a pardon in
return and as it turns out it was just
dana rohrabacher going in freelancing so
dana rohrabacher who's long been quite
friendly with the Russian government the
former California congressman he
confirmed in a new interview that during
a three-hour meeting at the Ecuadorian
Embassy in August of 2017
he told that Julian Assange he would get
President Trump to give him a pardon if
he turned over information proving the
Russians had not been the source
of internal DNC emails published by
WikiLeaks Rohrbacher is a conspiracy
theorist apparently who believes that
seth rich was murdered by the was
murdered by the DNC in order to cover up
their own internal problems and on all
of this kind of stuff so Rohrabacher is
basically freelancing offering Asajj
things he has no authority to do that
the media reported as fact in the
original instance ok just cos dana
rohrabacher was going to an offering
Assange something doesn't mean he had
any authority from Trump in fact
Rohrabacher said he didn't have any
authority from Trump so there's no
evidence for it at all the media ran
with it anyway so the media are itching
for this narrative that Trump doesn't
care about Russian interference Trump
should not play into this
the reason being number one because it
isn't true right in his administration
presumably will do its job law
enforcement will do its job in trying to
ferret this stuff out and number two I
don't think that Trump needs Russian
interference or wouldn't what do you
like it I have a hard time saying that
Trump wouldn't like it right I mean
because again Trump did have Donald
Trump jr. and company meeting at Trump
Tower with Russian lawyers who ended up
offering nothing they showed willingness
to solicit so I'm not going to you know
go as far as saying that Trump wouldn't
love to see it but I will say did from
doesn't need it and he'd be a fool to to
signal to the American public that
either he needs it or that he would
accept it in the aftermath of all the
hubbub at 2016 so the reason I say this
again is because if Trump is gonna run
against a very beatable Democrat if he
does not win reelection that is
basically going to be on President Trump
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like today I have to admit Donald
Trump is yeah I would I'd watch Donald
Trump's movie reviews I would I think
there'd be highly amusing so last night
at one of his big rallies he decided to
break out a movie review he's talked
about parasite now he hasn't seen
parasite so typically when you review a
movie you kind of want to see the movie
like I'll review a trailer and I'll
admit to you if I haven't seen the
trailer if I haven't seen the full movie
I've seen parasite
I think parasite was overrated I think
it was wildly overhead I could do a
whole segment maybe I will at some point
and why I think the parasite was so
wildly overrated and and why I think
that parasite won the answer basically
is because it is another one of these
class warfare metaphors that the Academy
seems to love is very obvious metaphor
it's kind of ridiculous metaphor but as
long as to Marxist metaphor for
materialism and how the Tyrael ism
corrupts people
brains and all this then the Academy
loves it in any case parasite was not
the best movie the in fact I don't think
is one of the five best movies of the
year but it's not a bad movie it's a
well made movie President Trump went off
on parasite because it's South Korean so
here as president Trump's movies reviews
all right
here we go how bad were the Academy
Awards this year you see
[Applause]
and the winner is a movie from South
Korea what the hell was that all of it
we got enough problems with South Korea
with trade on top of it they give them
the best movie of the year was it good I
don't know you know I'm looking for like
we're waiting let's get gone with the
wind can we get like Gone with the Wind
back please
Sunset Boulevard so many great movies I
like movies black-and-white movies who's
Betty Davis and believer what can we
have some good movies back television
Rocky Rocky's a great movie
I like Rocky a lot Godfather good movie
I don't like these new movies they're
newfangled things with movies okay I
mean let's be real the man is doing
comedy and his campaign rallies again
none of that's a problem form rather the
reason I put that in things I like is
because the part of President Trump that
is charming you logorrhea that is
charming is when he's doing stuff like
this like no one cares it's this is
trending number one on Twitter if you
think that has any impact on him it does
not but you know what that said run a
disciplined campaign like just a little
bit okay other things that I like today
so I've been watching this a new series
from Showtime it's available on Amazon
Prime escape at Dannemora it is quite
well made Ben Stiller directed at he did
an excellent job with the direction and
it starts with Benicio del Toro who is
sufficiently creepy as well as Paul Dana
who's been really underutilized by
Hollywood he's great in there will be
blood and then he's very good in this as
well Patricia Arquette isn't it as well
and she plays one of the worst
characters in screen history I mean
she's really quite evil in this but
she's stupid evil in any case here's a
little bit of the trailer for a skip ad
anymore which is the story of two
inmates at the Clinton Correctional
Facility in upstate New York who broke
out and of course then proceeded to be
on the lam for almost a month it was a
big story back in 2015 there's a little
bit of the preview I want to be a part
of your dream
[Applause]
you focus on something in your mind feel
it in your heart you commit to it
it will come true
so this is enough it's not the fastest
series it's fairly slow but the acting
is first first-rate and it really more
than anything else is is about the
relationship between these two inmates
and this and basically this prison
factory person now what's what's the the
the episode of the series that is the
most important is there's an episode of
the series very late in the series and
in which you learn what these guys did
what their crimes actually weren't and
completely changes the dynamic of the
series it's quite good it's definitely
worth the watch it's definitely ready to
her you can go check that out escape at
Dannemora it's good stuff and worth the
watch okay time for a quick thing that I
hate remember a representative Katie
Hill who was shtupping her subordinates
remember that remember how she was
slipping her subordinates and then she's
breaking up with her subordinates and
she was living in a throuple with her
husband and with one of her female
subordinates well now she's being
trotted out as a victim so this is what
the left does the left does this
routinely they they find somebody who
did a bad thing that person is forced to
leave because that person did a bad
thing and then they rehabilitate that
person as a victim of the right
so Katie Hill was not a victim of the
right she was a victim of the fact that
she is a pathetic loon bag okay not
because she is bisexual because whatever
because she was scooping her
subordinates I mean imagine that they're
a Republican Congress person a male and
he had basically used a subordinate in
his own congressional office for a
throuple with his wife that person would
be out of Congress in half a heartbeat
right half RV but because Katie Hill is
a bisexual woman and a Democrat right
not a Republican that means she's a
victim so George Stephanopoulos has her
on Good Morning America and tries to
rehabilitate her by suggesting that the
reason that she was Elstad from Congress
is because people are biphobic I didn't
know that's a thing biphobic I've heard
a homophobic before I've heard like
Islamophobic I've heard like I'm very
I've heard a RAC know phobic I've never
heard biphobic so there's a weird one
anyway here's here's Katie Hill
suggesting that the reason that she was
forced to leave Congress is not because
she's an irresponsible harridan who
mistreats her subordinates it really is
because she's bisexual which no one
cared about when she was elected because
she was openly bisexual then it's also
partly
cuz I'm a woman we haven't seen as many
right of the sex scandals with women but
the bisexuality is a huge part of it
right this is a this is there's a
fantasy element of it there's by phobia
that is rampant still and certainly
misunderstanding of what bisexual
bisexuality is and it's sensationalizing
right it's the headlines are much much
better than just oh congresswoman has
you know affair with a former campaign
staffer no actually if you'd had an
affair with a male staffer and he had
been in your employ at the time and then
you had apparently mistreated him that
would be a very very large story as well
it is worth noting by the way that the
senator from Arizona
Kristin's cinema is openly bisexual and
no one cares no one right no one has
made a peep about this because honestly
who cares like whatever man whatever
floats your boat it's free country but
the the attempt by George Stephanopoulos
to paint this as another example of
American bigotry I find it so tiresome
that the media have to constantly be in
search of examples of American bigotry
everything turns into an example of
America's intolerance if only we were
more European and our attitudes about
sex
well that would solve all of our
problems if only we were more lazy
farriner I feel like as a country we are
fairly lazy fair in our attitudes
towards sex
are we not I mean we had a President of
the United States in the 1990s who was
schtupping everything on two legs and we
basically got over it we have a
president right now who's been married
three times and was caught schtupping
porn stars and then paying them off for
their silence and everybody was kind of
like okay whatever man-- and again we
have a senator who's bisexual and no one
cares about that we've had House people
House members and Senators we have it
that hasn't been gay senator there's
certainly been House members where I
believe there's been a couple of gay
senators and then we have also the and
we have the first openly gay ambassador
Rick Grinnell right who's who's about to
become the first openly gay cabinet
official and only cares about that so
can we be spared the like when you do
something deeply wrong because you're a
member of a protected minority group it
must be because of the bigotry not
because you did anything wrong
so when Maxine Waters is routinely
corrupt that's not because she's black
when people point that out it's because
she's deeply corrupt there are lots of
black people in Congress who are not
deeply corrupt when we
sighs Barack Obama is present it wasn't
cause he was black it's cuz he's a bad
president when we criticize Katie Hill
it's because she was mistreating her
staff in a way that any other candidate
would be forced to step down any other
Congress person to be forces technically
she's bisexual but the attempt by George
Stephanopoulos to try and pin Katie
Hills downfall not on Katie Hill but on
evil Republicans who are secretly
staring at the pictures of her and her
paramours revealed on red-state sure I
know this is the fantasy world in which
Democrats live but it ain't real
okay Katie Hill was ousted because she
was corrupting because she was terrible
and cuz she's a bad person she was not
Elstad because she's bisexual already
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content so stick
around for that otherwise we'll be back
here on Monday we'll wrap up the Nevada
caucuses in a bowl for you will tell you
what is coming next as we move steadily
and increasingly toward a Trump vs.
Bernie Sanders 2020 man what a year this
is gonna be I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
bench Bureau show
the Benton Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director pavel
white house key technical producer
austin stevens playback and media
operated by nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
[Music]
you